in Paris France there's a secret
institution where the country's finest
furniture has been kept for over 400
years nestled at number one rue berbier
du you'll find the most accomplished
furniture artisans the Palace of
Versailles Hotel ma and Palace Elise all
have something in common it's  pretty
much certain that they have furniture
which came from here it's just these
guys are a little bit
shy
[Music]
Emmanuel
pic well my job today
is to preserve more than a hundred
thousand pieces of furniture
dating back to  the end of the 17th century and
up to the present day but as a result it is a
museum no the Mobilier national is not
at all a
museum it is really intended to furnish
you can find collections of
furniture from the collections of the
Mobilier national  in the
official places of the Republic the
residences of the President of the Republic
the ministries the embassies and a
certain number of other addresses
of so-called depository administration and
therefore what is this organization and how
it started it is a
uncomplicated long French
royishedav and their luxurious furniture
would go with them in 1604 King Henry I
decided that someone was needed to
oversee all of this moving around he
created a special role the steward of
the furniture repository they would be
responsible for maintaining transporting
and installing  the furniture as it
traved between the residences sound
correct yes it's correct great later
from about 1608 onwards the king set up
workshops to create high quality goods
for Royal use King Louis particularly
saw the potential of these workshops to
create economic prosperity and as a  way
to compete with foreign imports these
would establish France as a world leader
in craftsmanship and savoir
fa the institutions started to come
together and after a few
reconfigurations a prestigious showcase
for French luxury furniture was born
mobili national came to be well
over to you
thank you la  main mission is to
preserve the collections if the
national furniture did not exist and indeed
these collections would not be there
France is a country particularly
rich in decorative art which has become
known for the variety by the
diversity of these  styles of furniture and
we think it is important that the
authorities which govern us evolve
and work within a framework which reflects
the richness of these decorative arts
and from this point of view the Mobilier
national can be proud of
preserving furniture which  approached
Napoleon a throne of Napoleon the seats
which were at Versailles or or at
Saint-Clou at the time of Louis
Hall of Mirrors of
the table in front of which they signed
the
treaty and an aged piece of furniture is damaged so
must be maintained the restoration
today it must respect the
original technique of the piece of furniture we have
several restoration workshops at
Mobilier national l  '
seat carpentry workshop the
tapestry tucking workshop the
bronze chandelier workshop the carpet tucking workshop the
cabinetmaking workshop the
decor tapestry workshop the
upholstery workshop repairing a
chair that  can take half a day
or 3 days to restore a tapestry it
can take 2 years N nevertheless the
added value of the Mobilier
national workshops is that we can
afford to take the time necessary
for the restoration to be carried out in
the best conditions  possible the
Notre-Dame carpet here is a beautiful example
of a work whose restoration takes
time it is a somewhat
exceptional work because it is the
largest carpet that has ever been woven at
the Savonnerie Manufacture  and this
carpet had been a little damaged by
the fire that said it
had been in use at the cathedral for 150 years and
therefore it was a little damaged a little
bit damaged a little bit worn and
naturally the National Furniture was
offered to take on the work of this
restoration work since the carpet
had been woven at home so it is a
carpet to which we are
particularly
attached it is one of the great challenges of the
National Furniture it is in fact
not to  'enclosed in the image of a
conservatory of old furniture the arc
is what we call the
creation research workshop and which is responsible
for prototyping furniture and this workshop
is precisely planned installed here
works to help  young
French designers who do not yet have
sufficient notoriety to be
mass-produced the
National Library of France renovated one of
these sites therefore conceived the need to
change all the chairs therefore
several hundred chairs in the
rooms  reading and proposed a
new creation for this chair and
this new creation was entrusted to
a designer
and then prototyped by the
research and creation workshop of the Mobilier
national which therefore ensured
that this chair became a
reality in  2019 the Mobilier national
opened its doors for the
Heritage Days and welcomed a very large
audience it was a small revolution
in the house because until now
the Mobilier national prides itself on a
kind of culture of discretion and
everything  what was in the prince's service
was surrounded by a shape of gold we did
n't talk about it too much we weren't going to
visit it because it was the king's service
and full stop the people who visit
the National Furniture  on the occasion of
heritage days are rather
admiring they are surprised by the
variety of furniture that is represented
there I am happy that an institution
like the National Furniture can
exist and continue in the 21st
century from the attention that we  let us bring
our heritage collections to our
history and to this true part of the
national wealth which is this
know-how in terms of creation and
decorative art from the origins to our
[Music]
days